foreign
welcome to the show
hey how's it going today good how are
you
doing pretty good can't complain so I
started watching the material about a
week ago I'm on baby step two and as I'm
looking at my budget and my bills I
realized that I had my phone bill and my
insurance premiums should I include that
into baby step two or do I leave that
off to the side and making monthly
payments well what do you actually owe
debt on because your insurance premiums
Aren't Dead correct that's just a
monthly it's like a utility bill
right it's not necessarily dead but it
is something that I'm I'm going to have
to pay one way or another so that's why
I'm a little confused of sure you're
gonna have to pay maybe I should
included so my only debt is the phone
two credit cards at 500 another credit
card had a thousand
and uh motorcycle in the car but that's
above so I'm thinking maybe I should
just kind of pay off my credit cards
first then do the phone and the
insurance then pay off my motorcycle or
just pay them off smallest balance to
largest balance and ignore the interest
rate
okay and your insurance let me explain
how that would work so you're doing a
budget hopefully
and in your budget you're going to have
a sinking fund and you can create that
with every dollar they have a special
you Market as a sinking fund and so what
you would do is if your insurance bill
is let's say 1200 bucks a year that's
100 a month so in your budget you're
going to have a line item for insurance
at 100 a month and that hundred dollars
is going to stay in your checking your
savings account so by the end of the
year after 12 months of that you have
1200 ready to pay that bill
so we're not going to put that in the
debt snowball section and then as far as
your phone your phone payments you're
saying you have payments on your phone
because that's how they sell phones
these days because they want to keep us
in debt
yeah it's in the contract and all that
type of stuff so if you stop paying that
payment what are they going to do
they're going to come after you right
right so I would consider that debt and
include that in your debt snowball to
parse out the phone payment and if you
can pay it off in full find out the
amount you owe on the phone if it's 900
bucks we're gonna put that in the debt
snowball and get that phone paid off in
full
okay
um well it's not necessarily a phone
it's more the service for it so I don't
think I could pay off the services no
the service is just like your monthly
bill so it'd be like your license yeah
yeah and so just put that in your
monthly budget as a line item separately
and if you're using every dollar uh
which if are you not using it right now
or using a separate method
oh no I'm sorry what was that are you
using our every dollar budgeting tool
are you doing budgeting differently
uh no I have every dollar allocated to
something okay well we have an app
called every dollar I'm gonna gift that
to you for one year the premium version
to connect to your bank so you can drag
the transactions in it makes it really
easy to create those syncing funds I
mentioned it makes it easy to track all
of your debt in one place we have our
own baby steps tracker where you can
track your debt snowball to keep the
momentum going so hang on the line and
we're gonna gift that to you for being
one of our listeners and wanting to get
on this plan but uh it's that simple if
it's debt then it's going to go in the
debt snowball if it's not it just
becomes a line item in the budget
hey and man one of the strangest looks
I've received in my lifetime and I've
received a few is when I went to I think
it was at T or whatever and they said
hey I need a new phone how much does it
cost and they're like well we'll just
sign up on plan and I was like I don't
know I just want to buy a phone
and he's like uh hold on and then they
like a manager comes over and it's like
oh what do you want and I was like I
just want to pay for this phone like
well we'll just roll it into a plan oh
and I was like I get there but I just
want to buy this phone I don't like
owing people money this is before I work
here this is back in Texas and finally
the salesman they figured it all out and
he came back and said no one has ever
asked this question and I thought what
and he goes no one's ever asked can I
just buy this phone that's frightening
and uh they had to come up with a
special plan on how I could just walk
out with my own phone by giving them
money how can how can we figure this out
that's how we can train my money all of
America today is well what's the monthly
payment yes great I can do that yep
absolutely